[Musique]
l'enquêté la destination des jeunes de
18 à 30 ans qui sont en situation de
précarité dans les yvelines et qui
partant en vacances cet été
on leur demande ce qu'ils voudraient
faire pour vraiment faire un projet qui
correspond à leurs besoins leurs envies
leurs attentes
donc en gros on demande par exemple s'il
préfère la plage le parc d'attraction
des visites culturelles et on leur
demande aussi s'il veulent est partie
prenante du projet en devenant bénévole
dans la création de celui-ci
l'idée c'est qu'on va essayer d'aller
jusqu'au 15 juin pour répondre au
sondage pour pouvoir ensuite rappelé
tous les gènes qu'on proposait d'être
bénévole dans le projet et construire
ensemble
toute l'action l'idée c'est aussi qu'ils
puissent se rendre sur notre page
facebook pour y répondre
donc secours populaire des yvelines ou
sur notre site internet secours
populaire point fr slash 78 et qu'on
puisse avoir le plus de réponses
possibles pour faire vraiment quelque
chose qui corresponde aux besoins et aux
attentes des jeunes